hey everyone i'm susie jackson
hey everyone i'm susie jackson i'm an
editor here at bloomberg here uh
welcoming to you to a live chat with our
tech reporter mark german he covers all
things consumer tech with a specific
focus on apple so a big day for apple
and for mark today uh mark welcome to
the chat today
thanks for having me great to be here
great to talk to everyone and get
everyone's questions obviously it was a
exciting uh morning for apple fans
like myself
people yeah so
all day about it so i'd love to you know
dive in to you know get some thoughts
out great before we dive in i want you
to tell everyone about your power on
newsletter because if they're watching
this live stream they're probably
interested in everything you have to say
in that newsletter so tell us a little
bit about that
yeah so power on uh for those are
unfamiliar every sunday
uh comes out around 1pm eastern 11 a.m
pacific goes through the week's news
there's scoops and tidbits everything
about apple and other consumer tech
companies i had a little preview of the
event
today on the sunday newsletter there was
a little review i had of the ray-ban
spectacle
copy or whatever you want to call it
so yeah please subscribe it's growing
really quickly and really
well people are loving it and you can
sign up it's in my bio on twitter you
click the link you can sign up there
there's also a landing page on
bloomberg.com under the newsletter
section uh under the tech panel
bloomberg.com newsletters excuse me
boomer.com newsletters if you want to
find mark's email newsletter power on
and all of our other newsletters i'll
put a plug into if you're a bloomberg
time subscriber you get power on early
and you get full access to q a with mark
every week not just in this live stream
but every week so check that out mark
let's talk about the event today what
are your what's your initial reaction to
it
okay so it's a bit of a muted event
right i mean i called for apple to call
the new phone the iphone 13
but truth be told it's uh it's closer to
a 12s
they made the camera diagonal on the 13
and 13 mini so i guess as a design
change the notch is 20 narrower so not
significantly narrower but overall these
are small upgrades they're not even
saying how much faster the processor is
that's because i believe it's pretty
much on par just slightly faster
than the a14
last year
i thought the apple watch situation was
pretty interesting where they did not
give a release date for the apple watch
they basically said to be coming later
this fall
that's because there are some pretty
significant production delays uh and
some design changes and other
tweaks over the course of the products
development over the last several months
the new ipads the ipad mini just as
expected basically a shrunken down ipad
air ipad pro i think that's going to do
really well and people are going to be
quite excited about that
uh i don't like the new color of the new
phone the sierra blue i wish there was
like a matte black or a darker slate
color
i guess i'm going graphite this year i
have the quote-unquote pacific blue
right now looks pretty much like the
graphite but i think i'm going to go for
the graphite this year
apple watch bigger screen as expected
it's about a two inch display it's
specifically it's a 1.92 inches on the
diagonal much higher resolution 16 more
pixels but 20 more screen area
i think that's going to allow for much
better watch faces and apps apple
finally needs to allow people to release
their own watch faces or developers to
make watch faces to take advantage of
that display so i think there's a lot
more to come throughout the year as well
and uh the subtle event kind of muted
you were describing it earlier not a lot
of big design changes what do you think
that means for the general consumer of
someone who isn't following uh to think
to the pixel so precisely
i don't think it means anything honestly
i think that the redesign for the iphone
last year was fairly significant you'll
get a big new design next year
so i think this this just makes sense as
part of their two to three year design
cycle where they keep the the same
design it actually would have been
abnormal if apple were to change the
iphone design again after just changing
it last year i also think it's pretty
cool that the phones are just shipping i
mean they're going on pre-order on
friday so in a couple days and then
they're going to start shipping uh on
the 24th so about 10 11 days from now
last year not several week delay
so not surprising that we didn't see a
big design unveil today did anything
surprise you
uh did anything surprise me
not necessarily i mean i think we got a
lot of the features on the money uh in
terms of the new watch functionality uh
obviously uh as you've seen the the
watch casing is rounded like the current
model
not flat uh like i discussed i
anticipate that having been
a design change due to the complexity
that comes with that or design that
they're going to utilize in a future
generation but of course as everyone saw
their uh rounded
again this year even
they're actually even a little bit more
rounded than the current ones um
that new glass that they're using on top
of the display the crack resistance i
think is going to be helpful i can't
tell you how many times i've knocked the
watch into like a doorknob or something
or the corner of a table and shattered
the screen so you know hopefully that
you know that stands the stands up to
what apple's marketing
machine is saying it will do
yeah it does stay on the watch for a
second i know um some some health
updates not nothing really big happened
in health update space do you see
anything happening there maybe in the
next release
yeah so like as we said would be the
case there's really nothing new on the
health side of the watch certainly
disappointing given that you know
they're pushing this as a health device
right
next year will be a thermometer feature
probably in two or three years they'll
be the blood pressure feature and i
still think the time horizon on glucose
is at least five years out but those are
the those are the three big ones right
thermometer blood pressure glucose the
goal is to hit all three
they will it's just a matter of time but
the most imminent one
here from now will be the uh thermometer
which probably would have been very
handy over the last year and a half due
to
covid right but that's a great point
is there any competitor that's on their
heels you talk about a five line a five
year time horizon that feels like
forever in this space is anyone going to
catch up to them before that
see apple is the smart watch market
right they own well over half the market
there is 100 million of them at least
in use nobody comes close apple is so
far ahead in smart watches that i don't
really particularly think it's worth
anyone even attempting to come close
it's just not going to happen but i
think apple
eventually should do i don't know if
they're going to do it but they need to
break the ties completely from the
iphone at some point whether that's
creating a mechanism where you can buy
the watch off a shelf and set it up
without ever needing to pair it to an
iphone which by the way with the bigger
screen is now easier because they now
have the kit the flick type like
keyboard on there where you can actually
put a password if necessary fine
or make it compatible with android
release an apple watch app for android
one of those two things needs to happen
to really unlock the watch and until uh
until they do that the addressable
market is limited to how many people
have iphones huge market obviously but
if you want to loosen that a little more
you got to make some changes on on on
d-linking
sure
you've reported that that about half the
company's revenue is from the phones
though so do you think they're hesitant
to decouple the watch from the phone in
that way
um
i don't think so i don't think the apple
watch drives iphone sales i think it's
vice versa so
unlinking the two i don't think would
have a negative financial impact if
anything uh it would be it would it
would be quite uh positive i think uh
overall i i'm seeing we're getting a ton
of questions here on
on twitter we should let's go ahead and
take some
yeah let's take a few though so one
question from
jonas underscore 1799 he asks any ideas
when the apple watch will be released
that's a good question when was the last
time you've seen apple release an
iterative update to a product right and
not give a release time right even last
year when there was the multi-week
iphone delay they gave specific timing
they're not doing it this time because
of those major production delays and
some of the changes they had to make
later in development i would guess these
are coming out in november right if it
was coming out in october they would say
so i'll go further than that i would say
they don't even know if it's coming out
in november it could be coming out in
early december so i think the horizon on
there is unfortunately two months or so
i really want to get my hands on that
bigger screen so
do you think some of those challenges
are specific to apple are they bumping
into the the broader issues we're seeing
with global supply chain at the moment
i mean there is a broader supply chain
issue but this is not related to the
chip shortage or anything like that this
is mostly related to the screen and
issues producing the actual displays so
i wouldn't put it in the same category
as the chip shortage speaking of chips i
did find it very interesting that apple
ended up not explaining
what processor is inside of the new
watches right you would think it would
be like a chip but they didn't disclose
it that's if you go to apple's website
on the new watch they don't really
disclose anything about the watch kind
of have to dig around apple's website to
see
um
you know the 41 and 45 millimeter
configurations some of the other new
features um another question i'm getting
here is where is astro photography and
always on display the cameras are very
capable for astro but have they
intentionally skipped it
so
i don't believe astro photography was
ever planned to come to this year's uh
iphone when i wrote about the new camera
features about a month or two ago i
heard there's only three new features
specifically the camera
cinematic mode which is portrait mode
for video as you saw them really dive
into in the keynote photographic styles
which is like a new ai based filter
system to adjust skin tones more
naturally based on the other items and
colors in the photo
and then the third thing was prores
video recording so i had never heard
that astro photography was in so
i don't think that was ever a plan
however there are different modes and
different apps you can use because the
hardware is capable of that so i'm sure
you'll see a lot of third-party apps
pushing that uh always on display
yeah i had never heard that always on
display was was coming to the phone what
i had heard is that the screen hardware
would enable such functionality so it's
unclear when that feature would arrive
perhaps it's next year you out the year
after but that is certainly something
given the higher refresh rate that could
be accomplished uh on that new phone
just like it could be done
uh on the watch uh what other questions
are we getting here i've got one here
from yousef who says hi mark i just want
to hear your latest info on the mini led
macbooks is apple announcing them soon
yeah so they should probably be
announced uh in the next month or so i
heard they are several weeks away so
we'll see them probably late october
early november
oh these have been delayed time and time
again these were supposed to come out in
june and july and september they kept
pushing back
i personally think it's a mix of
problems related to the chip shortage
obviously processors at a complete
redesign coming to this machine and then
also the mini led is creating a ton of
complexity in the supply chain like we
saw with the ipad pro the new ones
earlier this year which also has mini
led on the 13 inch model so i think
you're seeing similar challenges in
production
uh for those as well
um what other questions are we getting
here hold on i'm seeing a lot on twitter
let me find some good ones while mark's
scrolling on twitter i'll remind
everyone to sign up for mark's
newsletter power on it's coming to you
every sunday all these inside scoops on
apple and all things consumer check you
can go to bloomberg.com newsletters to
find power on and all the rest of our
suite of newsletters coming from
bloomberg
and mark if you want to take another one
here from the stream while you're
searching for twitter how about that
we've got one from you can't unhear this
is the screen name would you recommend
someone with an iphone 12 not pro
upgrade to a 13.
iphone 12 not pro to a 13
okay so here here's my theory on that if
you're able to get a new iphone
without paying any money out of pocket
up front without increasing your monthly
payment if you're on an installment plan
and without needing to run a credit
check right if it's not going to cost
you anything
i don't see the reason if you're an
iphone
fan and you really wanted your device
not to get it now when you have to start
selling money out of pocket you have to
start selling your phone on ebay we need
to start doing trade-ins we need to do a
credit check through the iphone upgrade
program that creates complexity that
make it may you know give me or someone
else some pause to upgrade but all
things equal i don't see the point not
upgrading right
but going a little bit deeper this is
not that big of an upgrade right if it
is going to cause you a headache in any
shape or form
probably better off waiting to the 14.
what i did see though were some pretty
good
carrier deals like for example this
t-mobile deal so i'm on the magenta max
plan
through t-mobile i have an iphone 12 pro
max
so
what they're saying is i could get up to
1250 for my phone
um 800 in cash coming from apple the
rest coming in build credits from
t-mobile
essentially if i go from the 12 pro max
the 13 pro max through t-mobile it's not
going to cost me anything right and i
think that's going to be the case for a
lot of people so it just sounds like you
have to write a post about how to get
all these hacks to get around it that
might be useful to folks asking the same
question out there stay tuned to power
on this weekend but yeah i mean i think
you really do a little bit of research
and crunch some of the numbers sometimes
i like to pull out an excel spreadsheet
for these things you can probably get
the new device without paying anything
very little at most thing that worries
me though is that some of these upgrade
programs require credit checks i had a
friend who had like get the iphone
10
right and he didn't upgrade to the
iphone 11 because he didn't feel the
jump from the 10 to 11 was worth the
credit check so there might be a lot of
people who just don't want the their
credit score to maybe be adjusted a
little bit because of needing a credit
check right but the credit check
situation is dependent on which upgrade
plan you have that i think is related to
citizens bank with the iphone upgrade
program through apple but there might be
other plans like the apple card plan
that doesn't really uh impact your
credit score i have another good
question coming in here from sean
49 20. what are your thoughts on the
global store rumors now following the
event and lack of reference to global
star so if you remember my story from a
few weeks ago on the satellite
functionality coming to the device or
coming to the iphone eventually we said
this would be for future iphones who
said it would not be announced this year
that's exactly what happened right so
maybe there's satellite hardware tucked
in to the iphone 13 itself but the
functionality won't be coming till next
year globalstar seems like a likely
partner given that iridium and some of
the other satellite companies have
either said they're not involved with
apple or i don't have the technology to
do it globalstar hearing a lot of
negative things about them but it seems
like they're the most capable at this
point
uh they've been filing with the sec
documentation saying they've been
getting investments for an upcoming
service or product from a secret
provider and whatnot so it all adds up
that it could be global star but i think
the iphone satellite story is a little
too early uh but what i will say is this
is not something that you'll be able to
use to call your friend on the mount
this would be for god forbid if you're
in a
disaster a plane crash a car crash a
boating accident in the middle of
nowhere without cellular connectivity
that's what this is going to be for
obviously it's a niche feature but
there's some people who were in those
situations
yeah i've got another one here from
david satta who says when can we expect
an in-screen fingerprint sensor or will
apple not move on from face id
yeah i think face id is still the future
there was a period at the beginning of
the pandemic where apple was discussing
internally the need to probably move to
touch id
masks but then they added the software
functionality to better deal with masks
i believe there will be in-screen face
id in the next two or three generations
maybe for the lower end models they'll
do in-screen touch id instead or
relegate it to the display or sorry to
the to the power button so i think in
screen
face id is probably more promising at
this point than in screen touch id
um
the benefits of having face id over
touch id are tremendous obviously you
get the ar component uh you get emojis
you get animojis you get better
authentication obviously face id is more
secure to some extent because of the
variables you have in your face versus
what you just have in your phones
so there's a lot
how about some from twitter
let's see um so we have someone lk
writer saying he's really disappointed
uh that there is no in-screen touch id
i've heard that from
a lot of people i mean because of the
mask situation people want to unlock
their devices uh with their thumbs plus
sunglasses forget it yes um okay another
question coming here what about airpods
so apple
their production ramp for the new
airpods has started um there will be
another event next month so it seems
likely to me that the new airpods would
probably hit uh alongside that another
possibility
last year they sort of capped off the
year and released the airpods max
headphones right before christmas i
could totally see apple saving the
regular air pods for christmas time it's
sort of like a last product launch of
the year stocking stuffer type of gift
so i could definitely foresee that but i
would say for sure uh before the the end
of the year
[Music]
we got more questions coming in from
twitter why no usbc why no matte black
why no always on why no improved battery
on the watch seven where is the
stainless steel watch seven why do they
still sell the wash three and the iphone
12. okay a lot of questions
i think we're going to start with i like
all of these i'm going to start the last
question why do they still sell the
watch during the iphone 12
uh i don't know i don't think they
should sell the the watch three i mean
it's become sluggish fairly functional
for some people
i think they should definitely
not sell that anymore i can foresee them
when they launch the apple watch se2
next year keep the current apple watch
se move that down in a line to replace
the
series 3 watch the iphone 12 that makes
sense of course you're going to continue
selling the iphone 11. you don't want to
leave that gap now they have the 11 12
13.
i did see a steel watch on apple's
website
why not improve battery on the watch
seven uh i think it's too early to tell
they haven't released any specs on the
walk seven clearly there's something up
and i totally agree with you on the map
black iphone and the usbc it doesn't
make much sense to me that you've seen
in my power on newsletter that
the ipads all the ipads at this point
with the entry level
the mac
all usbc but the phone is still
lightning it's
kind of absurd it's time to either
switch to usbc remove the plug
all together i think
definitely want to have it going as well
talk about that a little more i thought
that was a really interesting piece that
you wrote we're just getting into the
the complexities of having so many
different devices that aren't all using
the same charger and now we're talking
about new products coming out and the
future of this where do you see it going
i see them going completely wireless the
end goal is to have a situation where
all your devices can recharge each other
they want to move to max the macbook pro
is going to move back to magsafe next
month uh or in november the phone has
mag safe the ipad pro will be getting
mag safe uh next year the glass back
eventually they're going to transition
everything over to wireless charging and
they're developing mechanisms so your
ipad can charge your phone your phone
could charge your airpods your airpods
case can charge your watch right they
really want to make everything be able
to charge each other and have one
unified ecosystem of charging um i see
we're getting tons of questions in here
now
um let's see
uh
hi susie mark does it still make sense
to get the ipad air 4 over the ipad mini
4 because the new i15 processor the new
features like center stage or wait for
the air five
well
all things equal
and air five if it adds center stage and
the a15 and the new front camera
it would be identical to the ipad mini
and the only difference is screen size
so the ipad mini
is what the new one is white 8.3 inch
diagonal and ipad air
i think it's 11 right or 10.9 10.9 or
11. anyways close enough it's your
choice
they're getting pretty close between the
ipad mini and the phone screen sizes so
i think that's going to be to put the
pro max and the new ipad mini uh side by
side for me personally
i always prefer the larger display but i
can tell you i loved the ipad mini back
in the day it's just become pointless
for me with the pro max
i went down to the smaller phone size
and i was worried about giving up
beautiful screen but i can hold it and
do things with one hand again so i
really appreciate that
the sc is way too small for me though
um
okay what do you think of the video
capabilities and the upgrades there
are they enough to make a large group of
people a large section of people upgrade
honestly i don't think so pro res video
recording
so limited in terms of the people who
are really going to take advantage of it
uh what i'm told is when you record a
prores video it's going to fill up your
onboard storage pretty dang quickly so
if you're going to do prores you're
going to want to get a higher storage
capacity
um iphone i don't see that you don't see
that it's changing all of our instagram
feeds to to look to a different
aesthetic that kind of thing it's going
to be a little bit further out of the
region than a general consumer yeah i
think it's going to be incredibly niche
these are this is for the people who are
trying to shoot movies and commercials
on iphones for whatever reason
um i do think the portrait mode for
video uh cinematic video is pretty dang
cool but again
why wasn't that available on a software
update for last year's phone
because they want to sell the new phones
right i mean i think it's i always think
it's so odd when they when they try to
sell the new devices using software
features that would work just as well on
last year's hardware but it is what it
is right they're a two trillion dollar
company and uh it's their responsibility
to not uh
you know go into the can right
yeah i've got another one here from dan
dieth who says have you do you ever see
apple getting into making first party
home kit accessories such as security
cameras like nest
i do i think that is something they're
absolutely working on it's going to be
quite a while before they launch it but
they definitely have a team working with
smart home devices right the way to
really bump up your own ecosystems is to
make a product as part of your ecosystem
if you remember before the
apple watch came out they were pushing
health syncing and functionality using
health kit
home kit they've done the home pod and
the apple tv but
nest is very successful
they're under google now amazon has all
those devices so then you'll see apple
try to compete at the very high end of
the smartphone or sorry the smart home
uh accessories market
i'm getting some more questions here on
twitter
thoughts on the ipad mini plus iphone
mini
versus the pro max so i think this
person is asking
should i get an ipad mini and an iphone
mini both of those or omax which would
sort of be in the middle and pay the
same price
my initial reaction would be why i have
two devices when you can have one that
basically accomplished the same thing so
for my money i'd probably get the promax
and not carry around
two devices
do you think this is getting too complex
for the average consumer that there's
there's too many devices that as you
were saying the kind of sides of the
spectrum of size are starting to meet
and what's that like keystone device
going to be that you don't know if it's
an ipad mini or a large phone what's is
there too much proliferation there
i think there's a lot of devices i think
there's a lot of consumer choice to me
the ultimate apple device would be
a foldable iphone uh pro max that
unfolds to the screen size of the ipad
mini so imagine a device that is about
the size of this and then you can hold
it and it becomes the size of like a
small
ipad right well the 90s are cool again
so flip phones might be the answer that
we've all been waiting for i think
samsung was absolutely onto something i
had the first fold if uh anyone watching
this remembers unfortunately my all
right i discovered unfortunately or not
unfortunately a huge flaw with the phone
where if you unpeeled the screen
protector which by the way they don't
tell you they didn't so you don't feel
that in that model uh destroyed the
whole phone anyways
whatever but like
that would be cool like if apple did a
foldable i i think that would be one of
the most popular apple devices ever
obviously there would be some
cannibalization there but you know as
apple likes to say we rather cannibalize
ourselves and have samsung do it by the
way i think samsung
is doing the right thing by going all in
on foldables you're going to see so many
more foldables from them i think they're
they're doing a great job
um some more questions i'm getting here
what features can make it a worthwhile
upgrade from the airpods pro to airpods
pro
2. okay so airpods pro 2 next year
a couple things they've been testing a
shorter stem
unclear if they're going to ultimately
go with that design because those are
still quite a ways away
other thing is fitness tracking so maybe
monitoring your sweat in your ear or
watering heart rate from your ear i
guess the eventual goal is to
put cellular in the airpods right and
make them a standard device just like
the watch i think that's going to be a
decade away though but
the future for the airpods is it's
pretty clear to me
some people call them an ear computer i
think it's absolutely a stretch and
that's pr spin to some extent
um but definitely something there on the
very very long term hopefully tell us
more about that
for those of us who can have a hard time
imagining how do you even interact with
your airpods to to more of a degree than
you already deal with i'm always trying
to tap the thing and it's not working
and that's my experience but you're
talking about going even beyond that
yeah so putting on board storage putting
cellular putting the ability to make
phone calls essentially being able to
leave home without the watch or the
phone and control everything through the
airpods right i mean people thought it
was unimaginable the small little apple
watch was able to get cellular back four
years ago you know wouldn't be surprised
that they could eventually jam in
cellular into their pods themselves
especially now that they're working on
their own modems and such they have
more flexibility to develop the hardware
alongside the modem alongside the
software whereas right now they're very
reliant on qualcomm and other partners
to basically shoehorn in uh the modem
designs that these
phone or the qualcomm and others media
tech and such have
created in the past themselves
a few more from the twitter stream
let's see we're getting
uh when do you expect the announcement
of an apple car
so i'm sure you saw doug field who ran
the apple car project from a hardware
perspective uh he bolted for ford very
interesting like wouldn't you think that
if you ran the apple car project for the
biggest company in the world and you
were successfully able to take that
project from from inception to launch
you would make
your legacy big time
don't you think that if doug field felt
that he was able to actually do that he
would have stuck around for it i
certainly think so instead he went to
four right four doesn't necessarily have
the greatest reputation
uh in the in the evu world in the
technology world so he left the iphone
maker behind for ford i don't think it's
a great look and now they put kevin
lynch in charge the only guy at apple
who's successfully brought new hardware
and software products the apple watch uh
to market so i think this is still very
much a software story uh to answer your
question pascal
i don't think they're going to announce
an apple car within the next five years
i think the the horizon on that project
is
seven to ten years it's it's quite it's
quite a ways away
yeah if you were talking about earlier
about the next watch really or some of
the health capabilities not even being
for five years and you're talking about
jumping to an entire vehicle it does
seem like you'd have to double or triple
that timeline
probably uh when can we see an apple
foldable that doesn't cost thousands of
dollars are there any barriers besides
cost i don't think cost is really a
factor for apple the iphone 12
sorry 13 pro max the top end now i think
i saw sixteen hundred dollars so i don't
think apple would blink twice to release
a twenty two hundred dollar foldable
iphone and i don't think a lot of cons i
don't think there's a lot of consumers
who think twice to buy it so i don't
think price is the issue i think it's a
technical issue i think it's how you can
make the screen not have a crease i
think if apple launches a foldable
they're going to want it to be basically
bug free so like there's three
generations of the samsung gold already
you'll probably get perfect by the fifth
generation right
apple wants perfect on generation one so
i think that's the hold up there
definitely they're reliant on third
parties like samsung for screen
psychology and so samsung is not able to
get the screen perfect even for itself
what are the chances they're gonna get
the screen perfect for apple very slim
so i would say two or three years any
plans on apple returning to a large
homepod or a soundbar for the apple tv i
think apple's finding that even their 99
homepod mini which by the way is just as
loud as an ipad speaker system i don't
even think that's selling particularly
well
uh
their next big thing in the home is sort
of this merged home pod and apple tv and
facetime device we'll see how that does
but like
it's incredible to me
how apple has completely failed at every
home device they've ever launched uh by
by any metric whether that's a financial
metric a customer satisfaction metric
tons of issues there the homepod
original cloud sounded great but the
functionality was so limited
do you think that'll change coming out
of this this year two years coming up on
now that we've all been home so much
more do you think that they will focus
in on this and having to get it right
team this is a big missed opportunity
the last 18 20 months i think they know
it's a missed opportunity but i don't
think they particularly care
i think the iphone sells so well the
apple excel so well that they're so uh
laser focused as they like to say on
those devices but i think this 2023
device that merges facetime an apple tv
box in a homepod
could be quite interesting depending on
how they price it and depending on how
unique the functionality is right it
would be sort of a leapfrog product that
amazon google have not really uh
perfected or done anything close to at
this point
um get any question here what do you
think happened with all the wrong leaks
this time
um
you know in terms of the wrong leaks
you're going to see misinformation
you're going to see people report things
that are incorrect uh every apple
product release cycle it's just the
nature of the beast i've been covering
the company since 2009 so what is it
2021 so what 11 12 years at this point
and i've seen it all i'm proud to say
that i always do the best i can to get
the most accurate information out there
and i think we did extraordinarily well
this time from all the features uh on
the camera the cinema mode pro res mode
photographic styles uh the smaller notch
the new processor core counts
the lack of major design changes the new
camera systems on all the new phones uh
the storage capacities the promotion so
i think we did great on the phone uh the
watch i think we did great as well
obviously we got the exact screen
resolutions we got the new interface we
got all the new watch faces all the
software changes there we had all the
ipad os and ios 15 and mac os monterey
stuff
uh the one thing that we mentioned that
didn't come to fruition was the flatter
edges uh obviously there had been some
design changes
and some production delays due to the
hardware obviously that was a mistake
hopefully that
launches uh you know in the future
and i'm fully expecting we also got the
ipad mini and the ipad 9 as well spot on
the other thing i'm expecting are the
air pods like i said to come toward the
end of the year
you'll see the macbook pro and some
other mac related stuff uh in the next
several weeks too so lots more to come
throughout the end of the year and i'm
extraordinarily excited to keep
reporting on that and covering that and
i appreciate everyone tuning in and you
know always entrusting me with the
latest apple info
great why don't we do one more from the
stream here and we can check twitter one
more time but in the meantime i've got
one from maturis paul who says do you
think india will be an important market
for the sale of the new iphones
oof well
what did stand out to me which i thought
was pretty interesting were the price
drops on the iphone 11 and iphone 12.
the iphone 12 now is 5.99
for the functionality uh which is mostly
what you're getting on the iphone 13 as
well that's i think a pretty damn good
price i think the iphone se price is
still quite aggressive
i think the phone that's going to really
be a big hit in india is going to be the
iphone the current iphone se
next year because they're going to come
with a 5g iphone se with some screen
changes and such next year when they do
that they're going to drop the price of
this iphone se whether through apple
officially or
carriers and such when they're trying to
dwindle down inventory so that i think
the current sc next year is the one to
watch with that price drop where they
can get to the sub 300 i think that
could be very strong in india i also
you know
it's not an apples culture to do this
i always thought they should do sort of
like a very low end phone specific to
those emerging markets parts of china
parts of india other parts of eastern
europe i think it could be a huge
success if they do a 200 250 phone into
the ios ecosystem rely on generating
revenue from services
i would strongly behoove
over lunch tim cook to do that not that
he needs my business advice
do you think that so that would open
them up to a set of consumers that isn't
just waiting for their prices to drop
but might not otherwise interact with
the company
absolutely because right now what you're
seeing is people waiting for price drops
in those devices until they to the right
prices are three or four generations old
right
what you want is a new generation
product that meets the price point for
your consumer
i think yeah our commenter here was
actually noting that his observation a
lot of uh folksinos in india are still
using the iphone 10 or the iphone x i'm
not sure which i should call it
the iphone x this is a good one from
dimitrio why did apple choose to
advertise the iphone 13 with the
delivery guy on a scooter despite news
of motorcycle vibrations damaging the
camera you'll have to ask their
marketing department sometimes they're
not talking to their engineering
department as much as they uh as they
should let's find one good uh one more
good serious question uh susie shall we
let me take that from here
well mark is searching i'll tell you one
more time if you want to sign up for his
newsletter it's called power on you can
go to bloomberg.com newsletters to find
that it'll hit your inbox every sunday
if you're a bloomberg.com subscriber you
will get it early and get full access to
a weekly q a with mark
so here's a question um what's the
difference between the iphone 13 pro and
the iphone 13
uh pro max is it only a matter of size i
have to check i believe some of the
camera specs are a bit different as well
in terms of the uh the sensor size and
then
obviously the camera software is the
same the pro res is the same so yeah i
think it comes down to
um screen size but i will i will look
into it and get back to you on twitter
that is actually a very good question
but i did notice the 13 pro max is a bit
thicker
very slightly thicker than the 12 pro
max so something to look out for if you
have cases that you want to reuse and
such so
great well mark thanks for chatting
today thank you to everyone for tuning
in and all the great questions if you
have anything you didn't get answered
just keep bugging mark on twitter and
he'll get them into the newsletter to
power on bloomberg.com newsletters look
for power on sign up there mark thanks
so much for chatting today and um good
luck writing up the rest of the
conference thank you susie see you next
time hopefully you can do this again in
october november with the next event